what about him Impressions is there
similarity between that and acting do
you
is there some fundamental way in which
you become the person if you have a
couple of the things you can just fill
in the blanks and I think the illusion
is that people think that that person
would say that and do that and that's
where the illusion of oh he really
embodies the character it's like once
you know someone's mannerisms you can
essentially portray a person from the
outside in yeah because you have all the
stuff on the outside and you can do it
and complete the illusion and if it's
for humor's sake you're gonna caricature
it therefore making the whole illusion
stronger and also weirder like I like to
on Mad TV if I did something two or
three times I get bored of it and I'd
start changing it and you know now he
talks like this and it's like what are
you doing I'm like I don't know it's
[ __ ] no one's late at night do
whatever you want but people still kind
of know
there's that character is especially if
you just call it out yeah there aren't
many impersonations that I listen to
myself do and go oh that's a good one
you know like a lot of people like like
I think Frank Caliendo is like the
greatest impersonator of all time he's
the best serious ridiculous it's
ridiculous and he's got a record button
and a broadcast ability that nobody has
I I really TR there's he's cracked
impersonations that I'm like how is he
how does he find he's got such an ear
but then he's got all the other tools
uh
I remember actually
my last season of Mad TV was also his
first season he comes up to me when I
met him and we're just up there in the
writer's offices and he goes hey nice to
meet you and he goes Louie Anderson
because I was doing a Louie on the show
and he goes Louie Anderson I go yeah he
goes hey you're doing it wrong I was
like oh am I Junior you know and he goes
he goes yeah you know because you do
this but you got to throw it up here or
sometimes I was like oh my God can I use
that of course and then we became you
know we became Fast Friends John Madden
is amazing it's just it's ridiculous
he really really embodies the person and
sometimes not even with the caricature
it's like it becomes the person so
strange totally yeah
I kind of feel like
you know do the impersonation and then
for not forget you're doing it but
forget everything else like just
just goof around of course to me it's
funny when some when you sound like
someone and you're saying the [ __ ] that
they would never say yeah well then
there's no you're you're letting go of
that part that tool in illusion that
keeps people in but to me it doesn't
matter because it's funnier so what was
the hardest impression for you to work
on I mean it's just somebody you
struggled with I was I I'll never forget
I had to do a Michael Caine in my first
season at Mad TV it never got good it
never got good it did it all week it
wasn't good we shot it the first take it
was [ __ ] second third and fourth it was
all [ __ ] well his voice is really
important right his yeah uh what is it
like it's like doing an impression of
Morgan Freeman or somebody like that is
yeah uh yeah you can get divorced yeah
that's my Morgan here's my Morgan
Freeman Andy Dufresne yeah
um
yeah I like your Trump too I don't know
where I heard it but it's it like I love
The Impressions you do that don't sound
anything like the original I can't do
Trump I I do though that's why it's
hilarious absolutely my trump now I say
just sounds like a like a fat B because
it's just uh yeah exactly and everybody
is a little drunk a little drunk yeah
just a little slurry yeah yeah I did do
an impersonations and then
not like just making it whoever yeah
yeah
that'll be the title of my muck uh so I
came was one you really struggled with
but yeah it was terrible it was terrible
and I could only hold my head a certain
way to do it because I had gotten locked
into this research tape that I watched
back then they would give us you know
now there's the internet but back then
you were if you were going to do an
impersonation the research Department
uh would give you a VHS tape and I
remember I got this VHS tape of Michael
Caine's acting school like this acting
class he did he's like right you know if
you're looking at the left eye and the
camera's over here see then the left eye
so you want to look at that left out for
hours you know and so I was like stuck
in this weird thing that made no sense
and uh it was terrible so the the actual
processes the record in the broadcast
yeah also wondered like what the process
is to to do
like a Frank Caliendo level impression
is it like listen to a lot of footage
I think he I think I mean I'm speaking
for myself I think you either have it or
you don't like you know if you can do
this one or you can't I think that
process for him is lightning quick
but I also think he he can look at
someone who he does not do and then by
the end of the afternoon he can do it